I was trying to think today,
what is it about Weezer?
What is it about your music,
Rivers, that gets to me?
I will say
it is incredibly
unique.
Like it is, there's no one else.
I just keep listening to the riffs.
I keep listening to the
construction of the song
and it just never sounds
like anybody else.
And I mean that in the
most complimentary way.
It's just, I always know
it's you when the song starts
and it's just fantastic.
And I don't know.
So I guess part of where I wanted to start
was figuring out where that comes from,
your approach to music,
because you have such a unique,
individualistic
approach to it.
When you were a kid, what
were you listening to?
Oh, I'm, I'm actually thinking
of The Sweater Song now,
cuz you just mentioned it, but
I remember the moment I came
up with that riff.
Yeah.
And I had, I was about 20, 21 years old
and I had been exposed to cool
music finally after moving
to LA from Connecticut.
Got a job at Tower Records
and started listening
to Sonic Youth and Pixies
and Velvet Underground.
And I was like,
"Okay, I'm gonna try to write
a Velvet Underground song."
And I sat down and came up
with The Sweater Song riff.
Mhm.
And I was like, "Yes, this is so cool."
And, you know, a couple
years went by, we got signed,
put out a record, it blew up, very happy.
1995, we end up playing this big festival
in New York City and Lars
Ulrich was there from Metallica
and I saw him backstage.
Yeah.
And the truth was, I was
a huge metal head in -
Sure.
In high school.
And that's really how I learned
how to play my instrument.
It suddenly occurred to
me like The Sweater Song,
that riff, that's actually very similar
to Metallica's Sanitarium.
(laughter)
And if you play them next to each other,
they're pretty much identical.
(laughter)
Just one-
(Laughter)
The Sweater Song's in a major key.
So I had to tell him that
right then and there.
That's what I told him when I met him.
And how did Lars take it?
He's totally cool.
We just ran into him again.
Yeah, he's just very, very cool.
And cuz recently we
covered Enter Sandman -
Mhm
It's been in our set
recently and we ended up
playing with him this summer
and we were so close to
playing Enter Sandman
right before they went on.
And, but, and we asked him like,
"Hey, is it cool if we play it?"
And he said,
"Yeah, that would mean we
don't have to play it."
(laughter)
So did you play it?
No, we didn't.
We chickened out.
Oh man.
That would've been amazing.
It would've.
What would the crowd
have done, I guess, say,
I mean, it would be -
That's the question.
Yes.
(laughter)
that is the question.
Well Metallica would have
to play The Sweater Song.
I know, yeah, yeah.
Um, I'd pay to see that too.
I, it reminds me of,
I know a comedian who's also a musician
is really a brilliant
guy named Andy Breckman,
who's written for Saturday Night Live
and a million other things.
And he famously opened for Don McLean
once at a festival.
And what he did -
Oh no.
He played American Pie
(laughter)
and did the whole thing and
Don McLean was not happy.
(laughter)
It just kills me.
That just kills me.
But yeah, I mean,
Metallica could handle it
cuz they've got a million songs, you know.
Not so Don McLean, sorry Don.
Well, he's got the Van Gogh song.
He's listening.
Oh, trust me.
Avid fan.